the senate worked late into the night
without voting on a bill to have a 911
style commission
investigate the assault on the capitol
later today republicans are expected to
block
the fact-finding effort into the january
6 riot by trump supporters
gop leaders argue other investigations
are underway and say democrats would use
a special commission
for their own political advantage as
chris van cleave reports
loved ones of a capitol police officer
who died after the attack
are still working to find support for
the bill
walking the halls her son battled to
protect gladys sicknick
brought her pain and loss to the
forefront of congress's debate over
investigating january
6. this was uphold the constitution and
right now i don't think they're doing it
brian cignac was one of three capitol
police officers seen here being sprayed
with a chemical agent and attacked
during the violent assault on the
capitol by trump supporters on january
6.
he died the next day after suffering two
strokes though it was determined he died
from natural causes
two men have been charged in his assault
cycnic's mother
wants the senate to authorize the
january 6th commission
passed by the house he was just there
for
for our country and for these guys and
he just was doing his job and he got
caught up in it and it's
very sad but republican leaders are
against the effort
i do not believe the additional
extraneous commission
that democratic leaders want would
uncover crucial new facts
or promote healing democrats say it's
essential to investigate the lead up to
january 6
to prevent future attacks there's no
excuse for a republican not to vote for
this unless they don't
hear the truth senator lisa murkowski a
moderate republican
agrees we just can't pretend that
nothing bad
happened or that people just got too
excitable
something bad happened and it's
important
to lay that out senator murkowski is
among the handful of republicans
expected to support moving forward with
the commission but democrats are
unlikely to find the 10 votes
they'll need from republicans to
actually make it happen
senator joe manchin who you saw in the
story there is a supporter of the
filibuster he has been asked if this is
a reason
to get rid of it he says he still
supports the filibuster
but just hopes they can find 10 good
people on the other side
anthony chris thank you